And thanks for your interest in
this topic. Effective altruism,
philanthropy as a for profit and ever
and the Al shortly delve into what that
means for profit thinking and charity,
how that can be a meaningfully combined.
Um, yeah, let's start off with a
definition of what effective altruism is.
It's a practical philosophy
and social movement,
which you might have heard of that
uses empirical evidence and reason to
determine the most effective ways to
benefit others in global society. Now,
that may sound good, but it doesn't
tell us that much. Um, of course.
Um, in any case, there are two conceptual
components, altruism and effectiveness.
Altruism is essentially, um,
the conceptual opposite of,
of egoism.
So it means that we're sort of
practically oriented in our action towards
helping others as well,
and not just considering our self interest
and effectiveness means that we're
trying to,
of course optimally achieve our goals,
including our altruistic goals.
So we're trying to maximize the
probability of a, of goal achievement.
Um,
now why should we be altruistic
at all? One might wonder, I mean,
in economics there's also, I
mean, there are various, uh,
prevalent theories of course, but, um,
there's a big strand at least in, uh, in,
in western economics saying, well,
you know, we should be selfish,
a utility maximizers so that
might raise the question,
why be altruistic at all?
Why be interested in, in,
in benefiting others too.
And there are various, uh, thought
experiments and arguments to,
to justify this practical orientation.
So imagine you're in the unfortunate
position of a firefighter faced with two
buildings, uh, to burning
buildings. One big one, small.
And let's say there are a hundred people
being trapped at the moment in the big
building and,
uh,
just one person being trapped in the
small building and they also received the
information that unfortunately, it won't
be possible to save all of these people.
So you have to, you're faced with
this moral dilemma. You're either, um,
can save these 100 people in the big
building or the one person in the small
building. That's the moral dilemma
you're in. And you know, for simplicity,
let's say that you have like in either
case, the 100% success probability,
so you'll succeed,
uh,
at saving these 100 or the one person
depending on the choice you make.
Now of course, there's always a third
option as well if you're the firefighter,
you could just decide to,
to go have a beer instead and I'm and
not be bothered with the situation.
So this will be the non altruistic
choice of course. And uh, yeah,
maybe the selfish choice, the
pure lust, selfish choice,
just go have a beer and
ignore the moral catastrophe,
the suffering and the imminent
deaths there. Um, but you know, if,
if we agree that three
is not an option as, um,
most people do when faced with
moral catastrophe, then yeah,
we need to choose between one and two.
And yeah, I mean it's a, it's a tragic,
it's a sad choice because somebody
is going to suffer and die anyway.
But it seems that clearly
in such a situation,
we would opt for the lesser evil and the
lesser evil here seems to be saving the
100 and not the one.
So here we'd probably go for a
option one and save a 100 people.
And um, this, so if we agree you sort of
with the background reasoning here then,
um,
that's an argument for two things.
One that we don't just have
selfish or self interested goals.
We have at least some
altruistic goals as well,
at least in situations of
moral catastrophe. And two,
we care about the numbers.
So when helping others, it doesn't
just matter that we are helping.
It does also matter that we try and help,
um,
the greatest possible number of people.
Um,
there are further arguments which you also
may have heard of, um, originating in,
in practical philosophy.
This is a drowning child thought
experiment going back to a philosopher,
Peter Singer.
So imagine you're walking past a lake
or a shallow pond and you realize that a
child, a small child is
drowning in there. Um,
you look around and you can't see any
parents or anyone else that would be
willing and able to help.
And the realize that this child's
life depends on what you do now.
So you can walk into that pond or
that lake and just safe the child.
There are no complications,
no risks or dangers involved to yourself.
Um, so you could just walk
in and save her life. Well,
that's not entirely true.
There is a little complication
and it's the following.
You're wearing pretty expensive clothes
and expensive shoes. Maybe your,
you happen to be on your way to
an important meeting. Let's say,
uh, you're expensive suit
and shoes cost, whatever,
a total amount of $1,000. And
they realize that, you know, if,
if you're now running or jumping into that
pond and lake and no risk to yourself,
you're going to ruin the
clothes and the shoes.
Let's also assume that there
will be no replacement.
So you'll just have to buy a new
suit and new shoes for $1,000.
So then the question is,
would you save the life, um,
under these circumstances, in that
situation? Or what do you not? Um,
unsurprisingly, the vast majority of
people say, ah, they would save the life.
Of course, if they didn't really
existentially need these $1,000,
of course it can construct a
situation where you're like, yeah,
I'm going to be starving if
I'll have to, you know, uh,
spend 1000 in addition to what
I'm spending anyway. But you know,
if you're still going to be comfortably
off, if that's just going to mean, um,
a little less luxury in your life, then
most people say, yeah, in that case,
it's really a no brainer that
they would save the life.
And this also shows that we do indeed,
or most people do indeed have
important altruistic goals as well,
and they would be willing to sacrifice
quite a bit of money in order to achieve
these altruistic goals,
to reduce the suffering of others
and save the life of others,
at least if that doesn't
put themselves in,
in sort of an existentially very
uncomfortable or dangerous situation.
But, so if we follow the reasoning
behind these two thought experiments,
the firefighter and the drowning child,
um,
that may have pretty significant practical
implications because we can then ask,
well, okay, now we do know that there
are also burning buildings out there.
There's a lot of suffering out there.
A lot of people are dying maybe from,
from preventable causes that
we could do something about.
So let's say if we have on our bank
account $1,000 or, uh, you know,
maybe many times as much that we could
donate and we would still be comfortably
off. Um, why don't we do
it? So I mean, if, if it's,
if it's a no brainer to save a
drowning child in that situation,
then one can ask,
well,
wouldn't it also be just equally
irrational and the no brainer actually to
dominate a lot more if we're not
already doing it? And then of course,
try and figure out,
yeah,
where this money could go the longest way
because it's important to save as many
people as possible as we saw in
the first thought experiment.
And that's precisely what the effective
altruism movement is trying to do.
Of course, if we follow the spirit
of these thought experiments,
then one action point is, yeah,
trying to check out the material,
the philosophical material,
the scientific, the economic,
the empirical material on
strategic do Gooding, um,
where should we donate our time or our
money if we want to make a difference?
Then one standard action point,
um,
within the effective altruism movement
has been trying to donate at least 10% of
one's income. Now, when I
first heard of this idea,
donate 10% of my income, I was
like, yeah, but that's like a lot.
And yes, I do have altruistic goals,
but I'm not a moral saint. Um,
listen, this too much of a challenge
isn't this sort of over demanding,
but then when you actually reason about
it more and check out the happiness,
psychology and happiness economics
behind it, many people conclude that yes,
you know, it's quite
unlikely. So if you live in a,
in a rich country and earn a good salary,
it's quite likely that,
that you'd be worse off,
uh,
when donating 10% of your income
each month. And quite the opposite.
There's quite solid happiness,
economic and happiness,
psychological research suggesting that
donations often tend to make the donors
happier as well.
So it can be a win win.
And this is why many
effective altruists have, um,
decided to donate at least 10%
of their income. And, uh, yeah,
it's quite astounding what
can be achieved in this way.
So currently on a global level,
there are a few thousand people at least,
um,
that strongly identify with
effective altruism. I mean,
maybe already tens of thousands that
maybe loosely identify with the tenants by
the few thousand that have decided to
donate 10% or more and have taken the
pledge.
This pledge is not legally binding,
but it's sort of personally and maybe
socially binding a pledge to donate 10%
over a lifetime. And in aggregate,
these pledges are already worth,
uh, several, several billion dollars
in sort of promised donations.
And these donations are now happening.
So it seems possible. And the movement,
this is only just starting essentially.
So it seems possible to compete with, uh,
with billionaires actually
with this strategy,
even if we're not billing
there as ourselves. Um, the
other main action point,
this third effective altruists of course
don't just try to donate money but also
time.
Um,
there is an organization
called 80,000 hours,
which provides career advice to people
interested in making as much of an
altruistic difference as possible.
On average,
we work about $80,000,
uh, in our lifetime.
And of course it's both in terms of
the personal stakes and in terms of the
stakes for the world at large,
the altruistic stakes,
this is a huge decision. What
are we gonna do with these, um,
$80,000. And it turns out that
sort of standard, traditional, um,
career advice that people
have been receiving if they
were interested in making
an altruistic difference isn't very useful
or very rational. So, I mean if you,
if you Paul people and ask them for
examples of like standardly altruistic
careers, many will for instance,
say doctor doctor in uh,
the developing world,
that's like a standard intuition.
But if you think about that,
if the goal is to make as much
of a difference as possible,
you need to work on something
that wouldn't happen otherwise.
So if you take the job of a doctor and
if it's the case that if you had not
taken that job,
somebody else would be doing it,
then maybe you're not
making much of a counter.
The counter factual difference actually.
And in some cases it can be a
much better strategy to say, uh,
decide to go and earn as much money as
possible and then give quite a large
fraction of that.
For instance,
in order to enable several other
people to become doctors in developing
countries. So with that sort of
strategy often called earning to give,
it could be possible to make a much bigger
counterfactual difference and also to
multiply once impact. And of course
that's just one consideration.
These considerations could
go in either direction.
It depends on what the biggest
bottle necks are. I mean, if,
if money isn't the big bottleneck, then
probably earning to give won't be, uh,
that promising strategy. So it, it
depends on the specifics of course,
but it turns out that traditional
altruistic career advice, um,
often isn't very useful.
Now another question of course,
is, well, what are the biggest,
um, metaphorically speaking,
burning buildings out there?
Um,
uh,
traditional focus of do gooders has
been just turning to local problems,
problems in, uh, in our own society.
And there are sayings like charity
begins at home and so on. Um,
but if we strive to make the
biggest possible difference,
that's not a very plausible focus
area because at least if we live in,
if an enrich in developed countries,
it's,
it's quite hard to actually save a
life for say, a few thousand dollars.
And most of the time,
totally impossible.
So if we look into our
health care systems,
it usually takes several hundred
thousand dollars in order to save a life.
And health care economics, uh, can
calculate that pretty precisely.
But because of this dynamic of
diminishing marginal utility of money,
it's,
it tends to be a lot easier to save
lives and reduce suffering and advanced
society in poorer countries.
So I'm a more plausible focus area with,
for instance,
we are looking to the refugee crisis.
I mean we can roughly a look
at them at the victim counts.
People that are suffering turns out about
50 or 60 million people are currently
a categorized us as refugees,
but it seems that there are much bigger
burning buildings still. For instance,
global poverty,
extreme poverty still affect
about 800 million people.
The standard definition is of of extreme
global poverty is an individual living
on less than $2 per day.
That's purchasing power parity of course.
And that means usually means permanent
undernourishment I'm suffering from
diseases that are actually totally
treatable because we can't afford any,
any medical treatment and so on.
So global poverty and health is a really
big um, burning building as it were,
a really big cause area.
Um,
and other sort of general cause area,
uh,
that effective altruists
tend to be interested in is,
is global catastrophic risks.
Because of course when we're dealing with
risks are for potentially global scale,
well literally everybody on earth could
be affected and not just the present
generation but also
all future generations.
That's also a consideration and
important to many effective altruists.
So if we think that the numbers count,
the victim counts are important,
then um,
it seems that at least
if civilization goes on,
most of the people that will ever live,
we'll of course live in,
in the future. So at this could then
lead to an argument of the sword. Well,
of course the present generation is,
is intrinsically important and
certainly very instrumental. Important.
But all the future generations
taken together could,
could be enormously and overwhelmingly
important if there's ways to positively
affect their wellbeing.
Um,
and of course some global
catastrophic risks are environmental,
some are political, international
warfare say some are technological.
And there's also of course an
overlapping area between all of these,
I mean nuclear war of course
at the intersection of
technology and international
politics.
Um,
but there are technological risks of
various kinds and also some stemming from
our action or are omission. So,
for instance, one cause area,
some effective altruists are interested
in is, is biotechnology in general.
So biosecurity,
of course here there are global
risks from just harmful action. Yeah.
If you consider synthetic biology,
the possibility to create artificial
artificially create bacteria or viruses
that could cause pandemics. Um,
so that, that's certainly a risk.
But then some risk also could
sort of stem from our mission,
our failure to advance
certain technologies.
I'm abroad because area some effective
altruists are interested in is
transhumanism of thinking about the
human condition from a far future
perspective, biologically
informed perspective. Um,
and some sub cause area there is trying
to fight and ultimately eliminate aging
for instance.
So if we take a fire,
if you'd take a far future
perspective and let's say it's,
it's techno technologically possible to
sort of fight diseases and the diseases
of old age to a point where we're
really no longer aging in a meaningful,
uh, biological sense.
So if that is possible,
it seems like if we take
sufficient technological
action to bring it about that
could be a huge benefit. And in a sense
maybe of course, you know, that's a,
that's a separate long discussion.
To what extent are biological condition
also represents a catastrophe in the way.
But this is a case where
technology of course, you know,
through the advancement of medicine has
already brought us huge benefits and
where failure to act now to invest in
the right kinds of maybe sort of very
visionary in the Utopian research could
also mean that certain catastrophes go
on for longer than would be necessary.
So eliminating aging as maybe a
speculative buy their cars area that some
effective boundaries have been
interested in and other cause areas,
animal suffering.
I mean this is also like
a long philosophical and
empirical at debate, but uh,
so if we suppose that animals are
conscious to can suffer as well,
and if say intelligence
is not super relevant for,
for moral status. And that seems to be
what we believe for humans. I mean we're,
when humans are concerned, we're
usually not saying, well, you know,
these humans say children,
small children are less intelligent,
therefore they're suffering matters less.
If we're not going to go for such an Rdm
and then we might reason, well, okay,
you know, animals might be far
less intelligent than we are,
but if there's good evidence
that they can suffer as well,
their numbers are also enormous. Um, and
maybe there's something we can do to, uh,
to reduce their suffering as well.
So some effective altruist have
taken that perspective and,
and are therefore trying to, uh, to
do effective work in that course area.
And there's more cause areas of course.
But that's just the rough overview.
And as you can see,
unsurprisingly, I mean,
the world is a hugely complex place,
um,
especially also when it comes
to trying to improve it.
So that's just sort of one
consideration. What are the biggest, um,
burning buildings.
But then of course,
if we want to know more precisely and
more specifically what the highest impact
opportunities are for us specifically,
more considerations will be relevant.
So scope of the problem that's sort of
the size of the burning building is just
one, uh, one relevant consideration.
I mean, another consideration,
needless to say is the solvability
or the tractability of a problem.
So if you have like two
problems, one big, one small,
and if it turns out that the big problem
is just not solvable, not realistic,
less soluble then well, yes, you know,
working on it won't be effective and
it could be more effective to work on a
small problem with highest solvability.
So that's definitely another, um,
relevant consideration.
Um,
a third one is neglect in society and
this is based on the sort of economic
assumption that activist resources,
so donation of time,
donations of time and money also tend
to have diminishing marginal returns.
So if, if, say you're one of the very,
if there's a big problem out there in
society and the you happen to be one of
the first people to help address it,
then the chance is much higher than
you're going to be able to make a big
difference that maybe you're going to be
able to make contributions of time and
money of ideas, uh, that
wouldn't happen otherwise.
But if the problem isn't
highly neglected in society,
so if there are already a huge
numbers of people addressing it,
both in civil society and in politics
may be in research and they're just one
additional person there
contributing money or time,
then the probability of course it will
be much lower than the are gonna make a
huge difference.
That wouldn't happen otherwise.
So neglect and society is definitely
another relevant consideration.
Last but not least,
personal fit and comparative advantage
also of groups and organizations and then
of individuals is, is relevant
as well. So, I mean, yeah,
if you have like a big problem that's
highly solvable and neglected in society,
but it's just a very bad fit, you don't
really have any like required skill,
you can't really make a huge
contributions to that problem.
Maybe it's still better
to work on something else.
So that's definitely also
an important consideration.
Your interests, your skills,
um, your motivation of
course, you know, if,
if you're an effective altruist,
a core thing to work on is also minimizing
the probability that you're going to
burn out at some point because that that
would of course hurt your impact big
time.
So all of these should factor into the
overall assessment and that can of course
get hugely complex but
also very interesting. Um,
now let's zoom in into
specific cause areas and,
and look at some more examples and also
then specific data that enables us to
make a cost effectiveness
and impact evaluations.
Um,
in terms of global health,
of course that's strongly related
to two general global poverty. Um,
there are various diseases that affect
a huge number and kill a huge number of
people every year and every day. So for
instance, the so called big three malaria,
tuberculosis, HIV, killed many more
people each and every day than say,
political violence and oppression and
warfare has tended to kill in a year.
Now that's another thing.
Of course.
I mean I'm not saying that
political action can be effective.
I mean quite the opposite.
So I mean,
even in terms of trying to fix
global health, ultimately if,
if you can sort of go for concert at
political action, systemic action,
that can be hugely effective.
There are also risks to that.
But it does seem like many do gooders
do seem to sort of prematurely jump into
politics because that's been
the traditional focus. Yeah,
we knew we need to address something
politically or we need to address
specifically political problems.
But actually if we just
look at the victim counts,
it's not obvious that this should
be the focus. So as I mentioned,
if we consider these big diseases,
the victim count at least has
tended to be much higher. Um,
the solvability is also seems very
high, at least in principle. Uh,
the medical technological solvability or
preventability very high in principle.
That's also often like a huge
complication with politics.
It's so messy and it's unclear whether
your campaign will succeed in song
neglect in society also
comparatively high.
So of course a lot of money is
going into medical research,
but the bulk of the money is going into
research that aims to address diseases
that are prevalent in western
societies, in rich societies. Why? Well,
one reason is that you can make a huge
profit there because they're going to
sell the treatment to
people in rich countries,
whereas it's much harder to make
a great profit addressing malaria,
which predominantly affects,
uh, the poorest people.
But in terms of achieving
our altruistic goals,
if we care about helping
as many people as possible,
this can be a great focus
area. Of course, you know,
trying to address just the diseases that
tend to affect the poorest of the poor.
Um, now, interestingly, empirical studies,
empirical data shows that there are
massive differences in cost effectiveness.
So in terms of amount of lives saved,
amount of suffering reduced between global
health, different global health, um,
interventions.
And um,
so the title of the talk said that
effective altruism is sort of trying to
approach, um, altruism in
charity in a for profit way.
And I didn't mean to say that we're
attempting to make a monetary profit,
not at all, but it's sort of the
mindset of trying to maximize something,
maximize a profit.
But here of course the profit is being
defined in terms of lives saved and
suffering reduced.
And interestingly,
this hasn't really been the traditional
focus of charity because in traditional
charity, what gets emphasized as sort
of more the emotional side of it, right?
I mean,
maybe you have a relative that died from
cancer and of course that affects you
deeply, emotionally and
very legitimately of course.
And then you're emotionally moved with
your sort of immediate compassion to do
something about that. And uh, effective
altruism missing, trying to counter that.
It's just saying, yes, let's take our
compassion. Let's take our emotions,
let's take our heart.
But let's also combine that with our head,
with our rationality or optimization
power that we are of course standardly
applying when it comes to
actual for profit investments.
You know,
in terms of monetary and personal profit.
Now when we're investing
there for monetary profit,
it's totally obvious that of course we're
going to be interested in the data and
where we're going to be highly
interested to know, well, you know, if,
if I'm gonna Invest into
that particular option,
what's the probability of success and
so on. How much am I going to achieve?
And this is precisely the kind of mindset
that effective altruism tries to apply
to the domain of altruism
and charity as well.
Let's look at HIV for instance.
So this is data from the World
Health Organization have like various
interventions that a one could
go for antiretroviral therapy,
condom distribution treatment,
and then uh,
at the bottom prevention through education
for high risk groups and mass media
education.
And you can see the estimated the
impacts based on a randomized controlled
trials in many cases can vary. It can vary
a lot. As you can also see by like the,
the varying shades of the bars.
Um,
the uncertainty is also quite
huge. So these traits there, um,
and the faint depart that
represents the uncertainty,
the intervals that we should probably
rationally have based on the studies.
So the uncertainty is huge, but we can
also see that despite this uncertainty,
which should of course factor in
the expect, the differences in,
in impact are still enormous.
And so if we follow the initial thought
experiment of the firefighter and the
greed that the numbers
count in altruism as well,
then of course it's crucial to factor
this information in when making donation
choices.
Another example is MOLAP malaria
prevention and uh, this is actually a,
a cause area or a sub cause area that does
particularly well, tends to do better,
at least at the moment. I mean
this can also change, you know,
based on the situation on the ground
changing the available evidence,
changing a bout.
But malaria prevention is a standard
intervention that's currently recommended
by effective altruists organizations in
the space of a world poverty and global
health. So with organizations such
as the against malaria foundation,
you can distribute,
purchase,
distribute one bed net for just $5 and
this is going to protect two people that
can then sleep under these nets.
And this offers really strong protection.
Of course,
most infections happen at night when
when people are sleeping and uh,
yes, in many, many randomized,
dozens of randomized control trials,
which is really good evidence.
I mean this is not physics of course,
but it's not the hard science by
many standards. But, uh, it's,
I mean this is backed by
really good evidence, uh,
comparatively really good
evidence in that space. Um,
and so yeah, of course, if
you scale up these numbers,
if you donate 100 k a then you
can protect for decay people.
That means many villages or like my whole
football stadium say and donating 100K
is quite easy for most people
actually in their western,
in rich societies. I mean, you
don't need to donate 100 k one goal,
but you can maybe if you
donate five k a year,
well then you're going to get up there.
If you donate 10 k a year anyway. Um,
and so it's quite amazing
what we can actually do. Even
just justice individuals.
Um,
the estimated cost per life year
saved is just $150 with that kind of
intervention. So that's pretty amazing
with an, with a donation of $150,
that doesn't affect many or most
people in rich societies at all.
We can actually give a poor person
one more health for Year of life.
And then of course, yeah, we can calculate
of course based on that, the cost,
the average cost of saving a whole
life. Now, of course, strictly speaking,
we can't save a life at the moment
because everybody is going to die.
So we'll need a, the abolition of
aging there through biotechnology. Um,
but what health care
economists do is to stay.
They'd talk about what the
cost of one life saved, uh,
as equivalent to saving
30 years of healthy life.
So that's usually what health
care economists mean when
they say saving a life.
So 30 years by the, yeah, this is
the rough cost here for one year,
one healthy year of life.
Um,
there are various organizations doing
sort of in depth charity research, um,
collecting data, analyzing it, um,
doing the relevant calculations and uh,
yeah,
the leading organization currently there
is gift well Gif world at work and uh,
yes they are extremely transparent. You
can check out all of their research, um,
on the website if you're interested
and they're coming up with top
recommendations for where to donate
based on their calculations every year.
And of course there's some fluctuations
if the evidence changes. Um,
generally speaking,
global health seems to be
a really promising cause
area because there are these
huge medical short run benefits.
And then as some studies suggest,
of course there are also tend to
be long run societal benefits. Um,
it's our one randomized controlled trial
suggested that kids that were able to
sleep under bed nets and
we're protected from malaria,
laid there on 10th tended to earn,
they missed much for your school days
and later on for instance tended to earn
20% more than kids that didn't have
the privilege to sleep under these bent
nets.
And another advantage is that,
I mean these are some worries that are
often discussed in these debates where
I'll,
you know,
but in terms of development aid of course
there have been many failures as well.
So many people are actually rightly
so quite cynical about the impact of
development aid. And indeed there
have been many failures. But I'd say,
well that's just an additional argument
for effective altruism for like being
serious about the data and
trying to figure out what
actually helps and what may
harm people. So even if we believe
that's sort of all of the uh,
development aid,
maybe also the state sponsor development
aid that's coming from western
societies was like maybe net
neutral or maybe even net negative.
Just statistically speaking,
there must be at least some
interventions that are positive, right?
So if we assume that all
of the interventions that
we've sponsored in terms of
development aid where like net neutral,
then probably there's some distribution
where some interventions are like
harmful, many are neutral
ish and some are really good.
And what effective altruism is
about is sort of trying to find an,
isolate the really good ones and
scale them up. And of course in our,
and the advantage of working in health
is that this seems to be like maybe the
paradigm example of a universal good.
I mean even if people's
cultural preferences vary a
lot and people's conceptions
of the good life very
a lot. Well, you know,
everybody needs to be healthy in
order to achieve any other goal.
So this is kind of a, of a universal
goats that seems safe to promote.
Um,
now taking this further,
what about uncertainty
and risk? I mean, yes,
it's totally legitimate
to ask. Well, you know,
what's the probability that the certain
antipoverty intervention fails to have
the intended effect?
Or maybe there's even a probability
that it will have a harmful effect. Uh,
and of course we should factor
that in as well. And we can start,
you know,
at least in theory to address that
sort of issue by modifying the initial
thought experiments. I mean, what,
what if you have like a 50% probability
to save a drowning child, you know,
you know that maybe you're not going
to make it in time, time is short.
Maybe the child will still die despite
their effort. I mean, in that case,
if the situation is,
you know,
either not do anything or do something
and have a 50% chance of success or even
maybe just a 10% chance of saving their
life, we will probably still say, yeah,
it's worth it.
And then of course we can further,
we can introduce further
complications while if we have,
let's say an 80% chance to save the life,
but the 1% chance to
cause harm in some way.
Maybe there are other children in the
round and maybe we would, whatever,
you know, unintentionally push a
child into the lake or whatever.
I mean complications could happen
with harmful unintended side effects.
And then f and then we can try and reason.
Okay.
Under what circumstances
with wild probability
distributions would we still go
for it?
And uh,
we can also consider dilemmas like what
if we have a 10% chance to save 100
lives versus a 100% chance to save five?
What would you do? What
should you do? And um,
what are the thresholds maybe?
So maybe we could start with a 100%
probability to save a certain number,
go down to 90% and compare it to the,
to another post decision possibility.
And a standard framework for addressing
this kind of situation is the expected
value framework. So just taking
the probability times the stakes.
So here at 10% chance times
100 versus a 100% chance.
So one times five and the expected value
here would recommend the first option.
So all 0.1 times 100 equals 10.
But of course we could ask,
well,
but shouldn't we be risk
averse at least a bit?
Doesn't risk aversion makes sense.
So if we have a one 100% probability to
save five versus just a 10% chance to
save a hundred, we might feel uneasy
about going for the 10% option.
I mean, one replies, if
that's not a one shot game,
but if many people do the same or
if you do the same many times over,
well then you know, uh, due
to the law of large numbers,
of course you are going to
save more people. In fact,
if you go for the highest expected
value, uh, so that's one reply. Um,
but yeah,
even if it's one shot,
I think a pretty good case can be made
here for going for risk neutrality.
So expected value as opposed
to some risk averse function.
I think our risk aversion comes from
our being accustomed to thinking about
decisions,
situations that are about earning money
or making money for personal utility.
And if it's, if, if, if we're about
making money for personal utility,
then risk aversion seems
to make perfect sense. Why?
Because money tends to have
diminishing marginal utility,
at least in terms of personal gain.
So the first $10,000 that you earn
per year are the hugely important.
They enable you to survive the second
20 k that you add our bid list and so on
and so forth.
So that's,
that seems to be the dynamic
when it comes to personal gain.
But that same argument doesn't seem to
apply when it comes to altruism because
there, yeah, if you save the first
life, great. If you safe the second one,
it's not like the second one
is less valuable. It's similar,
really valuable to the
person, um, themselves.
And so if we're being altruistic,
I think we should not,
we should not assume that
they're already made,
that there's diminishing
marginal utility there.
And so this kind of argument for
risk aversion does no longer apply.
So I would probably argue for going
for expected value maximization.
And when it comes to altruism and
taking the probability times the stakes,
and this leads to a concept that a
effective altruists call hits based
philanthropy or hit spaced giving.
I mean, let's consider an example.
In the 20th century.
It's again from the health area,
smallpox killed more than 300 million
people up to its eradication in the 70s so
a huge evil in terms of the consequences.
That's more than all wars,
all genocides, all political
violence and famines combined.
So an insane, uh, victim count.
But we were able to beat it and have
since saved an estimated 60 to 120 some
uncertainty. There are 60 to 120
million lives since the eradication.
And so there's a pretty interesting and
complex story behind how that happened
and x untie it also seems quite unlikely
to succeed in our many people are
saying now it's,
these are crazy plans snuck on to
succeed in terms of smallpox eradication.
But the point is if
the stakes are so high,
then even if the success
chance is very low,
the expected value can still be enormous
and it can be extremely worthwhile to
pursue something that's most likely
to fail. So you're pursuing a plan,
deliberately pursuing an altruistic
plan that's most likely to fail,
maybe only has a 5%
success success chance,
but because the stakes are so high,
the expected value can still be enormous.
And so that's the concept
of sort of headspace giving,
trying to do maybe many things at once,
trying to have various individuals and
various groups or organizations work on
such situations of low probability of
success and high stakes of course the for
profit analogy, again, this,
his headspace investment.
I mean you can do that with
your investment portfolio.
Uh, it's if you have,
if you're pursuing many such situations
or opportunities at once with like low
success probability but high stakes,
that's also a form of hedging.
Needless to say,
due to law of large numbers again,
and this concept can be transferred to,
to philanthropy in very productive ways.
Now some applications,
um,
off headspace giving are to be found
specifically in the course of the area of
global catastrophic risks.
Some of them being the worst case climate
change scenarios, which might be like,
you know,
sort of really extreme global chaos
and maybe even some extinction risk.
But that seems,
I mean climate change seems pretty bad,
but the absolute worst case
scenario seem pretty unlikely,
but still the stakes are enormous.
Maybe nuclear war seems
unlikely at least on a,
on an extinction level
scale. But the stakes, again,
extreme buyer security,
maybe unlikely,
but it's not clear.
I mean I'm,
I'm also not claiming that with
these risks to situation is necessary
necessarily, uh, off the sword
that the risk is low probability.
I mean,
if the risk is high probability,
then we should be addressing it
all the more. But the argument is,
even if the risk is low probability
and even if our success chance of doing
something to mitigate
the risk is also low,
the expected value of trying hard can
still be pretty high and a further cost
area that some effective altruists have
been thinking about and researching is,
um,
artificial intelligence opportunities
and risks from a possible transition to a
superhuman intelligence
and how to maybe steer, um,
such a transition to
maximize the benefits.
And in order to conclude,
let's zoom in on this cause area briefly.
Um, I should maybe premise it by
saying that I'm not myself and a,
an AI expert.
I'm a trained philosopher and a
half done a lot of entrepreneurship.
And if you're interested in what the AI
experts in effective altruism have to
say more specifically, then, uh,
I'd encourage you to check out the
organizations and the websites that I'll
mention at the end. So this
will just be a brief, um,
intro and philosophical overview.
Um,
so many technical experts do seem to
predict the emergence of artificial
superintelligence.
So machines that outperform
humans in literally every,
a domain of cognitive interest.
Uh,
later this century that seems to be a
prediction that many technical experts are
willing to make.
And of course if that materializes,
it's likely to be a change that's more
disruptive on a global scale than the
evolutionary sort of ape to
human transition has been.
And this has been an extremely
disruptive transition of course.
So the transition from apelike
brains to human brains,
I mean up to the point where you know,
the goal achievement and the very survival
of apes of chimps depends a lot more
on us humans than it depends on them.
So if artificial superintelligence or
super intelligence is emerge and I mean,
you know, there are various scenarios,
maybe there will also be like a,
a corresponding enhancement
of our human brains.
There is scenarios there that are
possible. But I mean then it's, yes,
it seems quite likely that our goal
achievement and our very survival will
depend more on on the super intelligences.
Then it would depend on us.
And this raises the question well,
um,
will these AI's goals be stably
aligned with our goals or not?
And it seems that if they are,
if they are stable,
aligned with our goals,
then that could be the biggest opportunity
for humanity ever. I mean, of course,
uh,
technological progress has
brought humanity a great
many benefits and this could
sort of be the ultimate benefit.
Um,
maybe the last one mentioned we need to
make and in principle it could solve all
our problems because the tool that we
have been using of course in history to
solve problems is our intelligence.
And if we end up with a human with a
superhuman intelligence that's beneficial,
uh, meaning, uh, that's pursuing
goals that are identical with ours,
uh, goals that we'd consider good and
valuable, uh, then that could be, yes,
really the biggest
opportunity for humanity ever.
But there could also be
some risks, namely if, um,
the superintelligence his goals are not
aligned or not stapling aligned. I mean,
it could also be the case that they are
aligned at first, but then sort of, uh,
because there's further
developments become misaligned,
that could also be a problem.
So that could also be the risks,
the risks that we're going to be faced
with a kind of super intelligent power
that's not stable goal aligned with us.
So it seems that this transition
could be extremely disruptive.
The s the stakes could be enormous,
literally the biggest stakes ever.
And depending on whether, um,
goal alignment will be the case,
the outcome could be extremely
good or quite dangerous.
And that's basically the problem context
that many effective altruists have been
thinking about.
Now from a sort of more philosophical,
non technical point of view
also in the public debate, uh,
some people have been like dismissing the
whole argument for various reasons and
well their common denominator is
often that they think that, well,
the probability either of these
scenarios materializing is super low.
And even if the probability were high,
then the probability would be low of, uh,
are, are being successfully able
to steer the development in any,
in any direction that we would
prefer. So yeah, some people say,
well, the probability of, you know,
any fears of goal misalignment
applying is extremely low.
Um,
and the probability of goal alignments
succeeding through sort of a strategic
effort on our part is also extremely low.
And from this day conclude that yeah,
it's not a cause area worth
pursuing in any serious way,
but sort of from a decision theoretic
and philosophical point of view, I'd say,
well, um, even if even if
that's completely correct,
if that were totally accurate,
that let's say it were extremely unlikely
that superintelligence would emerge at
all or like they're very
far into the future only.
And if we also add that it's in any case,
extremely improbable that we would sort
of succeed with a strategic effort to
try and maximize the probability
of an awesome, a utopian outcome,
even if both of these points apply,
well the expected value could
still be enormous. So it even,
even even knowing that our deliberate
effort at steering the development is
unlikely to succeed,
even if that were the case,
the expected value of trying hard
could still be high. So that's I think,
an important point to make from a sort
of decision theoretic perspective.
Um,
and that brings me to the second part.
Last slide already.
Uh,
what I've tried to do in this
talk is give a brief intro,
like a justification for the spirit
of ea and an overview of like main
strategies and cause areas pursuit.
And last but not least,
I'd like to mention some organizations
and their websites if you're interested
in checking out the material in
greater detail. I uh, did mention Gif,
well,
um,
the charity research think tank mainly
focusing on the cause area of world
poverty in global health.
Then there's giving what we can,
which is an organization where you can
sort of take a pledge to take this 10%
pledge the dimension than several thousand
people have already taken this pledge
to donate 10% to the most effective
cause areas they can find.
There's $80,000 the organization providing
career advice in the German area.
There's the effective altruism
foundation doing various things.
Also providing some career
advice and donation advice.
And for the cause area of
Ai Safety specifically,
there's the Berlin based Foundational
Research Institute whose research you can
check out or a the u s based,
um,
machine intelligence research institute
mirror, which you may have heard of. Um,
and uh, yes, so as I said,
I'm a philosopher by training,
but uh,
you can find the computer science and
machine learning literature by people who
believe that this is an important cause
area, um, on these websites for instance.
And to conclude,
so this is sort of the animating spirit
behind all of these organizations are
keen awareness that this is probably
in the very real and urgent sense.
The situation we are in globally.
It may not feel that way evolutionarily
because we are still running on sort of
stone age brains and emotionally we have
a hard time grasping the situation of a
global village, which is really
an interconnected global village.
That's a historical first.
And so emotionally we're not
really able to grasp that.
But intellectually we are,
and it's probably through
that this is our situation,
but it's also true that having a
beer from time to time is supreme.
We strategically important, we need
to minimize burnout risk and a, yeah,
the effective altruist communities all
around the world are very welcoming.
And there's also community
in, uh, in Zurich here.
Pretty big community in Switzerland and
Germany. And Yeah, if you're interested,
these are also just the kind of people
that like to go grab a beer and, um,
and have a philosophical and
also technical discussions.
And with that being said,
thanks again for your interest and your
attention and I'm looking forward to
your questions and comments.
Thank [inaudible].